die deutschen bewundern philosophen die
sie nicht ganz verstehen weil sie
glauben philosophie müsse unverständlich
sein das sagt mein heutiger studiogast
richard david precht und versucht
gleichzeitig dieses vorurteil zu
widerlegen er ist der philosoph den
jeder versteht herzlich willkommen bei
phoenix danke ja wenn ich das so sage
der philosoph den jeder versteht ist das
für sie ein kompliment oder zucken sie
dadurch auch inhaltlich ein bisschen
innerlich ein bisschen zusammen
dazu gehe ich nicht zusammen ich bin
zwar nicht ganz sicher ob es stimmt aber
wenn man von vielen verstanden wird ist
das natürlich ein gutes zeichen
und es ist das anliegen der philosophie
seit alters her seit den zeiten von
sokrates und platon gewesen auf die
gesellschaft einzuwirken und das kann
man nur wenn man verstanden wird
wenn man jetzt komplizierte
philosophische sachverhalte auch klar
verständlich und einfach ausdrücken kann
warum sind dann hegel habermas und
donner so schwer zu verstehen
auch da gibt es sehr unterschiedliche
gründe also es gibt tatsächlich einige
philosophen die schwierigkeiten gehabt
haben sich auszudrücken
es gibt andere philosophie aus ihrer
sprache versucht haben eine form von
kunst zu machen das ist bei doro der
fall gewesen
also er wollte auch auf der sinnlichen
ebene über die ästhetik seiner
formulierungen wirken es gibt also sehr
unterschiedliche gründe warum
philosophen schwer verständlich
schreiben was kann denn philosophie
jetzt beitragen zur lösung der probleme
in unserer zeit
ja es gibt eine eine möglichkeit
philosophie zu sehen die ist mir sehr
sympathisch wie sieht philosophien eine
art supervisor funktion dass man von
oben auf die dinge guckt und versucht
die verschiedenen sachverhalte diskurse
probleme aus einer vogelperspektive zu
verstehen also die rolle des philosophen
als generalisten und ich glaube dass es
in dieser gesellschaft sehr stark an
diesen generalisten mangelt die meisten
leute sind sehr stark in einer
spezialisierten welt befangen das gilt
für politiker ganz genauso wie für
wissenschaftler und dass dieser blick
von oben geht der gesellschaft immer
mehr verloren und gleichzeitig ist in
einer zeit des orientierungs umbruchs
und orientierungslosigkeit das bedürfnis
danach
irgendjemand die dinge ein bisschen
sortiert oder beim einordnen hilft oder
von oben drauf guckt dieses bedürfnis
sehr stark okay geben mitten rein
klimawandel ist das wirklich das größte
problem unserer zeit dem sich alle
anderen fragen und ordnen müssen
ich würde den klimawandel nicht vom
ressourcenverbrauch trennen aber ich
würde sagen die ökologische frage dass
unsere wirtschaftssystem nicht mehr
weiter
die natur zerstören dürfen wie sie das
bisher getan haben ist die existenzielle
frage mein überleben der menschheit geht
das jetzt alles freiwillig werden die
menschen schon aus vernunftgründen von
alleine tun was richtig ist oder geht es
nur mit zwang
es wäre überraschend wenn sie das täten
oder das wäre das erste mal in der
geschichte der menschheit dass die
vernunft sich so frei und selbstständig
durchsetzt nein tatsächlich werden wir
um das ganze zu realisieren nicht nur
neue technik brauchen sondern wir werden
auch eine neue form von verzichts kultur
brauchen einige dinge die uns heute
selbstverständlich sind werden in
zukunft auf diese art und weise ich
selbstverständlich bleiben können wir
werden ohne verbote nicht auskommen und
ich meine man darf ja nicht vergessen
der sinn von verboten besteht darin
freiheit zu sichern
verbote gibt es im straßenverkehr da
gibt es regeln damit sie als
straßenverkehrsteilnehmer freimann a
nach b kommen und nicht in gefahr laufen
ständig überfahren zu werden oder an
gelöscht mit ihrem auto um das heißt
also der sinn von verboten ist die
bewahrung der freiheit dieser generation
und einer künftigen generationen und
deswegen muss man auch aus einer
liberalen grundüberzeugung heraus der
festen überzeugung sein dass hier
verbote brauchen
ich bin trotzdem etwas überrascht dass
ein mensch der ja an wie sie der ja ein
menschenbild der aufklärung vertritt
freie unabhängige bürger dass der so ein
loblied der verbote sinkt
wie gerade sagt da hängt das eine eng
miteinander zusammen also vom liberalen
gesichtspunkt sagt man nur so viel staat
wie unbedingt nötig aber eben auch so
viel staat wie nötig um die freiheit zu
bewahren
das ist im grunde um die klassische
formulierung von wilhelm von humboldt
die alle liberalen unterschreiben würden
wenn ich aber die freiheit der künftigen
generationen auf dieser erde zu leben
sich entfalten zu können die natürlichen
grundlagen die ressourcen zu haben wenn
ich die sichern will
dann wird es ohne vermutlich nicht gehen
also verbote dienen der freiheit wird
man muss man ja vielleicht ein bisschen
genauer darüber reden von welchen war
was wollen wir was man sie verbieten
also man muss ein bisschen konkreter
würden sie suvs flugreisen wohnungen
über 100 quadratmeter pro person wenn
sie das verbieten wir sind als erstes
sind mir die frage stellen was können
wir die technik lösen und das werden wir
in absehbarer zeit über technik nicht
lösen können also wenn wir sagen wir
können es schaffen sie das sehr viel
strom demnächst über erneuerbare
energien herzustellen und den vielleicht
gänzlich herzustellen dann ist energie
verschleuderung nicht mehr das gleiche
problem wie das dann ist wenn es mit
fossilen brennstoffen gemüt dann wenn
wir jemand statistisch angucken was sind
sozusagen die schlimmsten größten dinge
dann müssen wir mal damit anfangen
massentierhaltung zu verbieten
ja da müssen wir gucken wir müssen die
fleischpreise müssen wir deutlich
erhöhen
das ist einer der allergrößten
katastrophen im hinblick auf den
klimawandel ist zum beispiel
fleischkonsum dass wir ein ganz
wichtiges thema ist suv ist natürlich
ein ganz kleines thema
das suv ist einfach nur von der haltung
her so rotzig also auf jeden gründer
punkt steht auf jedem es ist ein
aufkleber drauf stehen die zukunft
meiner kinder und meiner kinder ist mir
scheißegal
ja weil wir haben in den straßen von
düsseldorf wo 30 prozent des gps fahren
wenn ich chancen für den installierten
kabul sondern das einzige einzige grund
wofür ich dieses auto brauche es status
und wenn man sich überlegt dass man den
status bezahlt und er kauft damit dass
wir unverhältnismäßig viel co2 ausstoß
machen dann ist das eine haltung die ich
nicht verbieten kann aber die wir sollte
ich zumindest versuchen zu echten also
dass das rezept wäre sowas wie
gesellschaftlicher druck
naja ich glaube dieser geste das ist ja
schade dass wir den gesellschaftlichen
druck brauchen denn offensichtlich
scheint es den menschen die großen wert
darauf legen ein solches auto zu fahren
von vernunft seither nicht gegeben so
seien die einsicht
zu haben darauf zu verzichten die
deutschen lieben ja untergangsszenarien
woher wissen wir denn dass der
klimawandel wirklich so ein
herausragendes problem ist und mehr ist
als die großen themen der letzten
zwanzig dreißig jahre atomausstieg
nachrüstungsdebatte waldsterben
das kam mir in schöner regelmäßigkeit
und und verschwand dann ja auch wieder
ja das wird ja nicht verschwinden also
99,3 prozent der wissenschaftler die
sich mit diesen fragen beschäftigen man
ihnen ein szenario auf wie in 20 30 40
jahren die welt aussehen wird und wenn
die polkappen schmelzen also wenn die
verstärkung in den sieben jahren
gebieten südlich der sahara so
weitergeht wie bisher wenn wir all die
klimaflüchtlinge noch einen bedingten
die dann alle kommen weil auf ihren
äckern nichts mehr wächst wenn wir diese
ganzen verschiedenen tänzen alle
hochrechnen
und dann können wir vielleicht nicht
ganz exakt sagen ob die antarktis sind
30 jahren geschmolzen ist oder grünland
aber wir können sagen dass die tendenz
dass da so passiert das team weiter
zunimmt dann das ist ziemlich schnell
passiert und dann haben wir egal ob das
in 30 oder 50 jahren ist ein zustand auf
diesem planeten der von gravierenden
auch politischen kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen geprägt sein wird
und ich meine das hat eine dimension die
weit über alles hinausgeht wie
atomausstieg dagegen ist der
atomausstieg letztlich ein luxusproblem
die klimakrise hat große teile gerade
der jungen menschen politisiert wenn man
der vorher dachte die lesen keine
zeitungen mehr interessieren sich gar
nicht für politik ist frei des future
plötzlich so eine neue 68er bewegung
unserer zeit ein ja es gibt einiges was
sie mit der 68er bewegung teil zum
beispiel auch die plakative anprangerung
der älteren generation
aber es gibt noch anderes was sie
unterscheidet ich meine bei 68 ging es
darum die gesellschaft liberaler zu
machen eine tendenz die wahrscheinlich
auch ohne 68 irgendwann gekommen wäre
hier geht es ja auch ein viel ernsteres
thema hier geht es ja wirklich um das
grundsätzliche thema das überleben der
menschheit zu sichern das ist eine ganz
ganz andere dimension als die
bundesrepublik vom badener zeit zu
befreien
deswegen finde ich den vergleich
manchmal ein bisschen abwegig es geht um
viel viel mehr als 68 letztlich hat 68
die benutzeroberfläche der
bundesrepublik neu poliert
hier geht es aber darum ein völlig neues
denken zu entwickeln dass sich die frage
stellt wie ist ein kapitalismus in der
zukunft noch möglich der nicht auf
gnadenlosen ressourcen verbrauchen co2
ausstoß angewiesen ist das ist eine
jahrhundert herausforderung der ansicht
mit dem kapitalismus zu dass er diesen
fundamentalen wertewandel also nicht
immer mehr wachstum nicht immer mehr
wohlstand dass er auch den bewältigt und
irgendein rezept findet das ist eine
unglaublich schwierige frage positiv
könnte man sagen dass der kapitalismus
sich seit es ihn gibt auf eine
unglaublich geschmeidige art und weise
jeder neuen herausforderungen angepasst
hat und von daraus könnte man sagen weil
es ist auch nicht ausgeschlossen dass
das diesmal auch passiert aber ich
glaube dass die herausforderungen die
auf den kapitalismus zu kommt die größte
in seiner geschichte ist wir haben ja
gerade über freiheit ist verführt
gesprochen finden sie dass guttenberg
ein tolles vorbild ist oder ist das eher
peinlich wie wieder eine junge frau zur
ikone stilisiert wird
sie hat sich ja nicht selbst zur ikone
stilisiert wahrscheinlich beides sein
aber sie macht so ist könnt ihr auch
beim design wie die öffentlichkeit mit
ihr umgeht
naja led oder ich würde meine person ist
ja eh sehr zur ikone person ist am ende
ja nicht so wichtig sondern das wofür
sie steht und wenn über die stilisierung
der person zur ikone die bedeutung der
künftigen klimakatastrophe anschaulich
und personifiziert durch jemanden
verkörpert wird dann ist mir völlig egal
was sich im einzelnen in jetzt um dieses
mädchen rang sondern wichtig ist was es
ausgelöst hat und dass die medien sich
so dafür interessieren ist im dienste
der sache ein glücksfall
die menschen sorgen sich um das klima
aber sie fürchten auch um ihre heimat
und um ihren arbeitsplatz und viele
menschen nicht alle aber viele menschen
reagieren ganz anders als so links
liberale intellektuelle und ich zähle
sie denn mal mit dazu das gerne hätten
also ganz konkret die frage warum suchen
so viele menschen ihr heil in der ard
also es gibt viele gründe es gibt viele
häufig genannte gründe
ich würde dann gleich noch einen
hinzufügen wollen also erst einmal in
zeiten des umbruchs und wir leben in
zeiten eines massiven wirtschaftlichen
umbruchs nicht nur ausgelöst dadurch
dass wir anders ökologisch wirtschaften
müssen als bisher sondern auch dadurch
dass durch die digitalisierung wären
eine zeit kommen in der in vielen
bereichen das menschliche gehirn durch
maschinen ersetzt wird das ist eine
unglaubliche veränderung und immer wenn
solche revolution anstehen das auch bei
der industriellen revolution so dann
wittern die menschen dass ihre
lebenswelt so wie sie jetzt ist nicht
erhalten bleibt das stimmt auch
und dann haben sie angst zumal die
digitale zukunft ihnen nicht viel
schönes verspricht und in einer solchen
situation besinnt man sich auf das was
früher war oder was man sowieso immer
schon hatte also auch fragen der
identität man denkt früher wäre es
irgendwo besser gewesen und
revolutionszeit und wir leben in einer
sind immer begleitet von restauration
zeiten also auf die französische
revolution folgt den ich eine wunderbar
funktionierende demokratie sondern 1815
kehrten die über wohnen könige zurück
und das rad der geschichte wurde wieder
zurück zu drehen weil man irgendwie
dachte man muss auch wieder in irgendein
paradies von früher zurück was nie ein
paradies war und ähnliche tendenz haben
wir auch es gibt aber noch einen anderen
völlig unterschätzten geholt wenn sie
ich bin ja sehr viel in den neuen
ländern unterwegs wenn sie sich städter
angucken wie chemnitz wie cottbus wie
suhl und so weiter da würden die meisten
menschen die aus dem westen dahin kommen
sagen da will ich nicht leben
übrigens ziemlich viele leute im osten
auch also viele junge leute die
abwandern
was ist da passiert da ist alles was
identität mal gestiftet hat was kultur
was gemeinschaft was zusammenhalt
gestiftet hat aus diesen städten
verschwunden
die leute sitzen größtenteils zu hause
man geht eigentlich nicht wenn die stadt
die stadt des überzogen von seriösen
ketten ein großer teil des einkaufs wird
über online handel gemacht
und alles das was gemeinschaft stiftet
das ist der austausch das ist dass man
andere trifft man sich auf dem markt
trifft und so weiter das ist versteckt
in diesen regionen
also ich versorgen und das ist ein
wichtiger punkt ich glaube dass wir
nicht umhinkommen eine online steuer auf
konsumgüter von 25 prozent zu erheben
damit der einzelhandel günstiger
anbieten kann als der versandhandel
wenn wir das machen würden wir nicht nur
dem einzelhandel helfen sondern wir
würden gleichzeitig dazu dass wieder
leben in unserer städte kommt und zwar
nicht nur nach suhl sondern auch in
meiner heimatstadt solingen in der jeder
dritte laden leer steht
das ist ja mal ein praktischer vorschlag
aber glauben sie wirklich dass man eine
eine technologische entwicklung wie
onlinehandel dass das sinn macht sich
dem entgegenzustellen also weil es ja
weil ist das nicht wie die
maschinenstürmer wir müssen für
fortschritt sein und gegen rückschritt
und was hier erleben durch den
online-handel ist ein rückschritt an
lebensqualität ein rückschritt an kultur
und ich halte das für eine revolutionäre
moderne maßnahme ihn zu gehen und zu
sagen wir wollen nicht den online handel
grundsätzlich abschaffen aber wir wollen
den online handel erschweren weil die er
sehen zu welchem kulturverlust gegen den
ständen führt und ich halte das für
fortschrittsdenken und ich halte das
nicht ein rückschritt gehabt bis jetzt
verstanden und und lass das jetzt mal so
stehen
ich würde den gedanken gerne aufgreifen
bei dem ganzen mehr dahinter steckt dass
sie sagen dieser dieses verlust
gefüllter menschen ich verliere da meine
heimat dass ich mich in meiner stadt zu
hause fühle ja so dass hunt doch
offensichtlich die die traditionellen
parteien verpennt und da haben sich dann
die rechtspopulisten draufgesetzt war
das waren da ja schon die ersten die
gesagt haben wir müssen unsere heimat
verteidigen auch wenn sie da was anderes
darunter verstanden haben als sie das
vielleicht hat ja wenn ich das meer hat
der besinnt sich auf seine
volkszugehörigkeit ja ist das der fall
dann der größere identität wenn ich
meinen identitäts rahmen im persönlichen
verliere also ich meine in der ddr war
eine ganz erheblicher teil der identität
die zugehörigkeit zu betrieben das darf
man auch nicht vergessen da fand auch
der größte teil des kulturellen lebens
statt viele dieser betriebe existieren
heute nicht mehr
und wenn man auf dieser ebene seine
identität verliert und da muss man sich
irgendwann suchen wo man noch zugehört
und dann kommen solche gedanken wie
volksgemeinschaft oder nation
sie treten im grunde um kompensatorisch
da ein wo das andere verloren gegangen
ist und holen die leute ab und geben ihn
irgendwo an das warme gefühl zu etwas
dazu zu gehören was gut ist ja ich komme
gleich auf die inflation noch aber aber
zunächst mal zur heimat also dass dass
die menschen sagen ich will mich in
meiner heimat zu hause fühlen ich will
mich da auskennen ich will meine
nachbarn kennen ich will dass im bus
meine sprache gesprochen wird dass meine
sitten und gebräuche doch noch was wert
sind ist diese dieser wunsch der
menschen berechtigt oder ist dass
irgendwas von gestern es gibt keine
unberechtigten wünsche auf dieser ebene
ja also wenn ich das gefühl habe ich
verliere irgendwo meine identität und
ich wünsche mir irgend etwas zurück was
schon früher mal schöner war das ist das
erst mal ganz berechtigtes anliegen
meine kritik an der afg besteht ja nicht
darin dass menschen diese bedürfnisse
haben meine kritik besteht daran dass
die parteien wählen die bei diesen
bedürfnissen am ende nicht helfen werden
sondern die sich einer entwicklung
entgegen stellen die nicht aufzuhalten
ist und diese wähler enttäuschen werden
das heißt also die falschen antworten
auf ein nachvollziehbares gefühl geben
was wir machen müssen es hier müssen
eingedenk dass viele menschen in diesen
gefühlszustand haben und zu überlegen
was können positive lösungen für die
zukunft sein und deswegen mal ein
beispiel von gerade 25 prozent online
shop steuer wird vielmehr für chemnitz
cottbus und suhl bedeuten an aufblühen
weil sie diese 25 prozent würde ich den
städten zur verfügung stellen das kann
hundert mal mehr wir wirken als alles
das was die afg erzählt zumal der
migrationsanteil in sachsen sowieso
äußerst gering ist es ja ganz ganz
erstaunlich dass in diesen umbruchzeiten
zwei parteien profitieren dass die afg
und die grünen die hauptthemen von denen
haben wir gerade schon gesprochen aber
die die klassischen großen volksparteien
irgendwie ratlos darstellen und ja auch
von tag zu tag schwächer werden warum
warum finden die da kein rezept naja
also die die medienlandschaft von früher
in der alles so fein aufgeteilt war in
eine angeblich linke spd und eine
angeblich rechte cdu
jeder hatte sehr einfache koordinaten zu
bieten und unter diesen einfachen
koordinaten konnten die volksparteien
sich sehr schön entfalten heute sieht es
so aus dass die menschen so viele
informationsmöglichkeiten haben und das
was man eine weltanschauung war zerfällt
in lauter einzelteile und weil das
überall in der gesellschaft ist geht
dieser riss auch durch die parteien
selber also jener flügel in der cdu
dermaßen gut findet oder friedrich merz
gerne als kanzler hätte ist was anderes
als diejenigen die hinter merkel oder
eine geräteabgabe bauer stehen im grunde
genommen passten diese verschiedenen
flügel kaum noch in eine partei das
gleiche problem hat die spd auch
zwischen olaf scholz und kevin kühnert
die dürften eigentlich nicht in
derselben partei sein und die partei ist
mitten zerrissen zwischen einem sich
links neu erfinden auf der einen seite
und der bestands wahrung des alten auf
der anderen seite sind seriöse
kandidatenkür der spd die gerade läuft
ich finde ich würdelos ich glaube dass
jeder kandidat der durch ein solches
let's dance verfahren gegangen ist wohl
jedermann sich eine partnerin suchen
muss um gewählt werden zu können um dann
bei 23 veranstaltungen einen redebeitrag
von 3 bis 5 minuten von sich zu geben
das ist das modell einer castingshow das
ist nicht in würde volle auswahl eines
spitzenkandidaten man muss sich ja nur
vorstellen wie die brand- oder gerhard
schröder hätte durch ein solches
verfahren gehen müssen um anschließend
kanzlerkandidat oder parteivorsitzender
zu werden
also wer sich einer solchen lächerlichen
prozedur aussetzt er hat am ende so für
ein würde verlust und man sieht auch
beispiel kramp karrenbauer da gab es ja
auch ein casting am ende wenn auch ein
kürzeres kasling es bedeutet überhaupt
nicht dass man den rückhalt der partei
hinter sich hat ich versuche trotzdem zu
verstehen was was die spd da gerade
macht und die cdu bisschen eingeschränkt
auch dass man eben irgendwie versucht zu
lösen das in der tat ganz diffuse oder
ganz unterschiedliche strömungen in der
partei sind haben sie ja gerade
beschrieben aber man will irgendwie
dieses prinzip volkspartei retten und
versucht auf dieses durch dieses casting
einen zu finden der irgendwie von allen
flügeln getragen ja ich verstehe den
gedanken dahinter aber man macht
selbstmord aus angst vorm sterben
also man trägt zur weiteren zur
förderung der partei bei durch ein
verfahren von dem man denkt das ist die
lösung des stattdessen vergrößert man
das problem wenn die spd hatte
eigentlich mit martin schulz einen
kandidaten der die seele der partei auf
eine
wunderbare art und weise getroffen hat
und der die verschiedenen flügel noch
anbinden können ist natürlich eine
unglückliche geschichte gewesen und
seinen wahlkampf die umstände sind ja
auch bekannt aber sie hatte damit noch
mal eine persönlichkeit
ich sehe jenseits von martin schulz im
augenblick niemand der die integrative
kraft hätte die verschiedenen tendenzen
und weltanschauungen diese in der spd
gibt zu klammern
und derjenige der am ende mit knapper
mehrheit dieses rennen gewinnt der wird
nicht die partei hinter sich haben das
war jetzt ein energisches cd für martin
schulz trotzdem hat die partei in
abgesägt also aus all dem was ihr da
jetzt erzählen ist da ja nicht viel viel
hoffnung herauszulesen für die zukunft
der spd
ich habe ja gerade gesagt eine sache
stellen wir noch kurz zurück dass der
nationalstaat er aus den worten die die
sie das gesagt habe habe ich ja eher so
herausgelesen der nationalstaat ist eher
was was von gestern viele menschen
widersprechen dem oder versuchen 1
rennen und sagen also demokratie und
sozialstaat das hat bisher nur im
nationalstaat funktioniert und ob ich
wirklich eine vernünftige debatte zum
beispiel in ganz europa hinkriege und
europa unser sozialsystem garantieren
kann gerade für uns deutschen wo wir
einen sehr hohen sozialstandards haben
das ist doch sehr die frage ich habe den
nationalstaat haben sie mich falsch
verstanden nicht in frage gestellt ist
nutzt mir leid ich bin ich kritisiere im
augenblick viele linksliberale die in
einigen punkten mehr europa wollen wo
ich nicht mehr europa will und zwar
nicht weil ich nicht grundsätzlich den
gedanken mehr europa schön finde sondern
weil ich denke das ist im augenblick
nicht die frage an der wir arbeiten
sollten sondern tatsächlich glaube ich
dass viele sehr wichtige veränderungen
im zuge des ökonomischen umbruchs
schalker nationalstaaten voraussetzung
also wenn wir unser umlagesystem was
langfristig vermutlich nicht erhalten
bleiben kann weil diejenigen die
arbeiten nicht mehr diejenigen
finanzieren können die nicht arbeiten
und die nicht mehr arbeiten wenn wir da
gewaltige umbauten brauchen dann werden
wir das nicht auf der europäischen ebene
schaffen sondern es müssen die
nationalstaaten machen und voneinander
abgucken
dafür brauchen wir national staaten nein
meine kritik bezog sich nicht auf die
einheit des nationalstaats die halte ich
zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt für
unverzichtbar sondern sie handelt von
einem gewissen kitschigen
nationalstaaten den nationalismus nimmt
nationalismus ist von gestern
nationalstaat ist von heute okay ich
würde gern ein bisschen noch über sie
persönlich erfahren wie wird man den
philosophen grunde genommen kann ja
jeder philosophierender philosophie ist
ja wie wittgenstein mal gesagt hat eine
tätigkeit
das heißt also wenn man auf einem
gewissen niveau ich hoffe intelligent
über die gesellschaft nachdenkt und eine
menge über das weiß was es alles so an
bisherigem nachdenken darüber gibt dann
kann man die tätigkeit die man tut
philosophierenden beginnen wir malen im
elternhaus ihr vater hat er zu hause
ganz große bibliothek aufgebaut aber
anders als sie hat er dieses nachdenken
über die zeit das bücherlesen und dann
formulieren was drinsteht nie zum beruf
gemacht ich habe das immer schade
gefunden mein vater industriedesigner
und hat seinen beruf jetzt nicht über
die maßen geliebt im nachhinein redet er
ziemlich gut darüber aber ich erinnere
mich in der zeit als er das war war
eigentlich nicht sonderlich glücklich
mit seinem beruf und sein großes
interesse oder seine flucht welt waren
tatsächlich malerei literatur
philosophie mit den dingen hat er sich
ganz ganz intensiv beschäftigt und diese
werte wurden auf uns kinder fünf kinder
insgesamt sehr stark vererbt und dann
holen wir geprägt bei uns zu hause war
nie die rede davon dass man später
meinen beruf ergreifen soll mit dem man
geld verdient weil sie den satz den fast
jeder bei sich mal zu hause gehört hat
den gab es gar nicht hat ein
interessantes eltern also also ihre
eltern waren erklärte atheisten und
marxisten war sehr engagiert im kampf
gegen den vietnamkrieg haben dann zwei
zumindest mit aus diesen gründen und
zwei waisenkinder aus vietnam adoptiert
obwohl sie schon drei kinder zu hause
waren wie hat denn dieses politisierte
elternhaus auf sie als kind und
jugendlicher gewirkt als normal aber
nicht in dieser welt aufgewachsen bin
war ich dazu sagen also mein vater hatte
sich intensiv mit marx beschäftigt und
teilte marxens analyse des kapitalismus
meine eltern waren ja in keiner partei
aber mein vater war der felsenfesten
überzeugung davon dass der kapitalismus
eigentlich eine extrem ungesundes system
ist
und meine mutter war eigentlich eine
klassische 68er in die aus protest gegen
ihr sehr konservatives elternhaus links
geworden ist aber es war in der tat so
mit den beiden adoptiv geschwistern aus
vietnam dass vieles was bei uns zu hause
erzählt wurde keine ähnlichkeiten hat er
wie immer die welt sein wie das bei den
nachbarskindern o bei den schulfreunden
war ich find das jetzt ganz interessant
weil wir hatten vor wenigen wochen jan
fleischhauer hier zu gast
und der hat gerichtet hat mit sehr
schönen worten wie das linke elternhaus
wie er aus protest gegen das linke
elternhaus zum konservativen wurde
warum war das bei ihnen ganz anders da
muss man zu jan fleischhauer sagen
irgendwann ist man aus der pubertät jahr
aus und kann auch wieder reifen also man
muss sozusagen eine trotzhaltung ein
leben lang zur marke konservieren
wundert mich doch ein bisschen also dem
vista adoleszenz prozess scheint zu
fehlen
aber bei mir war das so ich musste mich
ja schon dadurch dass ich positionen
vertrat durch mein elternhaus in der
schule zum beispiel befand ich mich ja
eigentlich immer in einer art
außenseiter situation
und wenn man schon in der schule mit
seinen meinungen tendenziell er aneckt
danneck man nicht auch noch darüber
hinaus mit seinem elternhaus also mache
ich habe meine pubertät nicht so sehr
gegen meine eltern ausgelebt als gegen
das umfeld in dem ich sonst gelebt habe
und ich glaube das ist der grund warum
ich also da jetzt nicht in die starke
auseinandersetzung gegangen bin da muss
man auch dazu sagen ich meinte auch
meine eltern haben ihre ansichten
geändert
es war was anderes eine starke linke
überzeugung zu haben anfang der 70er
oder in den achtzigern
ich war da ist ja auch eine menge
passiert also
sie waren ja nicht von anfang an
erfolgreiche haben wir berichtet dass
sie an ihrem roman die kosmonauten
glaube ich zwei jahre geschrieben haben
und am ende dann 800 exemplare verkauft
haben haben sie an sich gezweifelt
also ich glaube wie jeder mensch der bei
trost ist habe ich auch an mir
gezweifelt aber ich habe mir die frage
gestellt wie kann das sein dass ich
immer das falsche zum falschen zeitpunkt
mache aber ich habe ja bevor dem erfolg
von der bin ich mehrere bücher
geschrieben die nicht alle so erfolglos
waren wie die kosmonauten aber eben auch
nicht so wahnsinnig erfolgreich
und ich habe ja das was ich gemacht habe
bin ich gemacht um reich zu werden aber
ich musste mir immer gedanken darüber
machen wie kann ich meine miete bezahlen
und meine telefonrechnung
und da habe ich mir natürlich gewünscht
dass irgendwann mal was besseres dabei
rauskommt als diese furchtbare
geschichte mit dem kosmonauten ich hab
das halte das bis heute für mein bestes
buch und vielleicht ist das auch der
grund warum es nicht so schlecht
verkauft hat ja also das ist schon unter
literarischen gesichtspunkten
kompliziertes buch und daher alles jetzt
dann von natur aus eine relativ kleine
klientel an lesern ja und dann plötzlich
haben sie bewiesen dass er auch
erfolgreich können sie haben ja schon
gesagt wer bin ich und wenn ja wie viele
ich glaube insgesamt haben sie jetzt
über drei millionen bücher verkauft
warum lief das und das andere dich also
das war so nachdem ich vorher zwei
romane geschrieben hat gab es eigentlich
immer mehr stimmen die mir geraten haben
du kannst auch so gut so sachen erklären
so beschreibt sich ein sachbuch und da
ich damals frau kennengelernt habe die
drei kinder hatte und den ich auch
philosophie erklärt habe dann kam eben
dieser dieser gedanke etwas zu machen
das auch 14 und 16 jährige verschiedenen
können dann philosophie und das war der
ausgangspunkt der hinter wer bin ich
stand und dann war es aber nicht so dass
das buch sofort ein riesenerfolg wurde
das buch hatte eine startauflage von
10.000 exemplaren die haben sich dann im
laufe des herbstes so gerade so verkauft
und dann sagte der verlag habe gute
nachricht für sie wird rund 3000 nach
und das war genau die situation als elke
heidenreich das buch in der sendung
lesen hoch gehalten hat und ganz dafür
gemacht hat und gesagt wenn sie das
lesen will sich glücklich werden sie
glücklich und dann passierte etwas
geisterhaftes dieses buch stürmte an die
erste stelle der bestsellerliste
wie in einem traum war aber in keiner
buchhandlung wochen lang erhältlich so
dass ich mir auch vorstellen konnte ich
hätte wären würde sozusagen abdrehen
mittlerweile jemand immer gar nicht
vorstellen was sinnlich war dieser
erfolg gar nicht sichtbar
was hat sich denn für sie verändert als
sie plötzlich geld hatten
die angst war weg das ist meine karte
aus dem sparkassen- automaten nicht mehr
rauskommt das ist es ist eine ganz große
veränderung ich habe auch besser
geschlafen
früher musste ich mir immer die frage
stellen also wie handele ich mich durch
leben und als zweites die frage werde
ich jemals eine rente kriegen von der
ich leben kann
das hat sich geändert und diese
sicherheit die veränderten etwas in
einem wenn diese existenzielle grund
angst verloren gegangen ist die ich
immerhin zwischen 1995 und 2007 also
zwölf jahren gehabt habe und empfinden
sie erfolgreicher als belastung weil wie
gesagt drei millionen verkaufte bücher
das ist ja unheimlich schwer das
irgendwie nochmal zu toppen
ich denke nicht so kapitalistisch also
ich denke dass ich mit jedem buch was
ich mache ja dann wieder einen neuen
horizont und eine neue grenze erreicht
ich bin in der angenehmen situation dass
ich mich zwar über große verkaufszahlen
freuen dass ich aber nicht mehr darauf
angewiesen bin
deswegen ist es für mich nicht wichtig
das zu toppen in irgendeiner form ich
freue mich dass ich einen wunderbaren
verlag habe der mich die bücher
schreiben lässt die schreiben möchte
und bislang war es so dass diese bücher
nicht erfolglos waren
und ich glaube das einzige was mir
passieren könnte ist dass ich irgendwann
keinen erfolg mehr hätte dann wäre es
aber nicht mehr existenziell bedrohlich
ich muss nicht top sind sie ein
pessimist oder ein optimist ich komme
aus einem elternhaus in dem der
pessimismus viel deutlicher als der
optimismus beim vater ist ja sehr viel
pessimistischer
mein bruder und ich habe eigentlich so
von kindesbeinen an eine antihaltung
gegen pessimismus entwickeln wenn man
sich die welt rational betrachtet es ist
ziemlich einfach ein pessimist zu sein
aber ich denke mir immer ein optimist
der sich in seinen idealen getäuscht hat
hat immer noch ein erfüllteres leben
gehabt als ein pessimist der sich
bestätigt sieht das war phoenix
persönlich heute mit richard david
precht herzlichen dank sehr gerne
[Musik]